let's take a look at the weird biology
and anatomy of the new troll monster
from the newly released Norwegian
Netflix movie of the same name
let's start with the description as seen
in the movie The Troll is a gigantic
monster that was thought to be just myth
and fairy tale but in this movie we get
to find out that he was in fact not just
any troll but a son of a mountain King
from the Norse myths and was one of the
last specimens of his species alive
he was believed to have been hibernating
and slept beneath the Dover mountains in
the north of Norway only to be awakened
by the construction of an underground
railway tunnel he was a humanoid giant
that flourished in a tightly knit group
and that his family were killed for some
unknown reason hundreds of years ago by
human Invaders and the Advent of
Christianity
now let's take a look at his size as
confirmed by the paleontologists in the
movie The Creature was said to be 45 to
50 meters tall or 147 to 164 feet in
height judging by only the depth of the
footprints and their size but later in
the movie we get to see the trolls
standing next to a tall building in Oslo
and he stands approximately the same as
the 15th floor which means the troll
would be around 15 stories tall and when
converted into metrics that would mean
150 feet tall or close to 46 meters he
would be one of the biggest movie
monsters from this year 2022 and indeed
one of the biggest from Norwegian films
rivaling the other yachtnas from the
2010 movie troll Hunter
this troll has a very big head that is
bald but with massive Viking beard that
is full of plant outgrowths he has two
human-like eyes and a broad nose plus
two very big ears all senses that are
Amplified by his magical nature his
hyper nature his mouth bears a dental
structure close to that of big cat
species with two canines on the upper
jaw and two very big ones in the lower
jaw that are visibly larger than the
rest of his teeth the skin of the troll
is filled with Rocky osteaderms and
outgrowths that fit perfectly with this
terrain of the region a sort of
camouflage for the icy and desolate
geography of Norway he is bipedal with
two arms and legs but also a very long
tail that seems to be furry and a bit
like that of a tiger or a lion
now the trolls Anatomy is very similar
to us albeit in a gigantic way we can
see from the skeletons in the cave that
he is in fact a primate the skeletal
structure suggests the presence of a rib
cage a spine a pelvic girdle and the
adjoining bones of the legs and arms
although being a creature of Legend and
fairy tales he is still a biological
being and that he possesses organs and
organ systems a digestive crack that
allows him to eat people and animals
making him the apex predator of the
region with the very ape-like skull that
is seen in the cave these trolls
probably had a very complex nervous
system controlled by a brain that would
be very similar to ours having a large
cerebrum
the skin of the troll is the most
interesting part it has a very thick
epidermis that looks like rocks and soil
which overlines a dense and very thick
height as well its hair and beard are
made up of branchy and root outgrowths
which makes him a floral faunal specimen
the Rocky and plant-like other layers
protect him from explosions from fire
and even the most powerful tang and
artillery shells it is unknown as to
whether he can withstand a tactical
nuclear weapon but it is highly very
highly unlikely as the radiation from
that weapon will turn him into stone as
his entire biology is allergic to
ultraviolet light just like vampires
even a bit of this UV rays will turn
bone and flesh off the troll into stone
which is why sunlight is his greatest
weakness his ears are also very
sensitive to a certain frequency that
resembles judge Bells causing him
intense pain
the creature's main strength though is
his enormous size being roughly 150 feet
tall has a significant Advantage because
he can deliver a lot of damage to
structures military equipment and
anything at all he can endure missile
attacks tank grounds heavy bullets and
explosions as seen in the trailer and
movie
he also has the ability to hibernate and
effectively conceal from sensors being
virtually invisible to all spectrums of
light even the infrared sensors in
addition to these the troll can smell
the blood of a Christian and a Muslim
from a distance and differentiate
between the Believers and non-believers
of the Norse myths one that is described
as his hyper nature
so the stroll has a weird mix of biology
and magic in his Anatomy something which
is heavily adapted from folklore and
fairy tales anyway that's about it I
hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates and new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam